so everybody I'm
then I'm
looking to you today about yellow brick
and how we develop visualizations in
yellow brick yellow brick is a
open-source Python library for
visualizing scikit-learn scikit-learn
models some of the other related you
know utilities as part of scikit-learn
and we do quite a bit more there we go
so next up I really wanted to thank the
volunteers and you guys in the audience
for being here I'm one of the conference
chairs here and this was our speaker had
had to cancel so I put this talk
together but this talk has been in me
for about two years and this is one of
those things that we all kind of have
where we have something we want to talk
about the blog post never gets done the
talk doesn't happen but it's like
they're right so again I really wanted
to thank John and really all the
volunteers here we have about 25
volunteers that have just made this such
a smooth-running conference I've been to
several potatoes before and it's really
you guys are the key to it and you guys
was the audience here you know we have
300 350 people coming here and we put
this on as a community for you guys
because at one point we were sitting in
the audience and when kind of word came
up that pie data was gonna be getting
organized we said let's do it la is
ready for a pie data so as a committee
chair I want to say feel free to talk to
me about your experiences at the
conference you know things that you love
things that could have maybe been a
little better and especially if you guys
are interested in talking about that
about getting involved with the next pie
data hopefully in the next year and
lastly if you guys are interested in
yellow brick learning more contributing
also come and talk to me so outside of
that my day job I'm
a mobile back in developer at Farmers
Insurance
we're in Woodland Hills local it's a
great place to work I also run the
Pasadena Python Meetup
teach a lot of workshops and
introduction to Python and very applied
exercises in the public library and the
community up there and as I said I'm the
co-chair so about this talk I'm gonna do
a few things I'm going to introduce you
guys you you all to yellow brick as I
said a visualization package for
scikit-learn
and then I'm going to go through the
process of developing a visualizer and
this is something that in years of
bringing on board new contributors to
yellow brick there's kind of like a
process a strategy I've learned for
explaining to people how to combine
scikit-learn matplotlib and numpy into
kind of a pattern that is stable tested
well-documented that folks can use
downstream pip install it and normally
what I'm gonna be presenting to you guys
is something that I do one-on-one with
individuals or small groups and I've
been doing it for several years and
remember when I said there was this talk
in me that I wanted to share this is it
with you know kind of putting all these
kind of elements together and then and
and lastly most of the people that I
have kind of imported as contributors to
yellow brick they've kind of taken some
of these approaches to developing and
putting these kind of logics together
and testing them and shipping them they
they've kind of taken this approach and
they've used it for other projects
they've used professionally or you know
or whatnot so I have a couple notebooks
with some code examples in there I'm not
going to do live coding it's already
been been done but just kind of going
through the process and it's at my
github right there building a YB
visualizer
so yeah and then lastly yellow brick
yellow brick road we have in our
documentation and as a as a project
we're named after the illa brick road
and The Wizard of Oz so I'm going to
clewd
lots of photos you'll see in the talk so
what is yellow brick yellow brick
extends the scikit-learn API to produce
visualizations and captions captures
common workflows that that data
scientists and other data professionals
do it's built with scikit-learn
matplotlib and everything's kind of
glued together with numpy and when I say
common workflows data scientists we kind
of think of it as like the model
selection triple there is when you're
approaching like a problem you're number
one you're looking to engineer or find
the the the kind of the feature set that
is the smallest and most predictive next
you're trying to figure out the model or
the model family that is kind of best
suited to the problem and then after you
identify that kind of model or model
family then you're tuning the hyper
parameters to get to get the best
performance out of that and we've found
and I'm sure those of you who have done
this process before that you might have
a lot of scripts that are already doing
this you might have some some
visualizations or some kind of scoring
metrics that you're doing that you kind
of copy and paste and you apply to each
one of these problems in your workflow
yellow-brick as we kind of designed it
is to capture these make them really
well done
generalized visualizations that you can
kind of plug in to to your problem and
you don't have to kind of rely on those
those scripts constantly we have a
really simple API which for those of you
familiar with scikit-learn might look
pretty familiar step one
well I guess you wouldn't you have to
import stuff in Python right next
instantiate instantiate the the object
or here this is one of our visualizers
next calling a fit or a transform meth
on it pass
the the X&Y the features in the target
in and then poof so what is poof I'll
get into later but poof is essentially
matplotlib already took the draw
function so we had to use something and
being yellow-brick poof this kind of
sound cool like poof here's your
visualization so so you run that and for
this case you get parallel coordinates
so this is one of our feature analyze
feature visualizers parallel coordinates
this data set is for apartments if
they're occupied or unoccupied and this
is a visualization to essentially
quickly you as the developer or you use
one a potions problem to quickly
determine the feature separation from
this so here for this data set looking
at apartments that are occupied versus
that unoccupied you can see right off
the bat unoccupied apartments have a
lower level of light occupy apartments
have more light CEO - that one's a
little messy but the temperature is also
another one there's a general trend that
apartments with lower temperatures are
unoccupied versus ones that are occupied
kind of makes sense but sometimes to
quickly produce a visualization that
kind of tease that that out is you know
very helpful in you know in increasing
speeding up your workflow another
visualizer missing values so this is one
for horse colic and this is one
visualizing the positions of missing
value by feature and right off the bat
the my first observation here is that
there's some change in the data maybe in
the data collection technique so right
after the position by index after maybe
90 or 100 things kind of changed it
doesn't that seem pretty predictive to
you guys right off the bat as a like a
first you know first step and seeing how
you're going to select features another
one this is a one
our progression visualizers for
residuals so here you can kind of see
where where the data where the predicted
outcome or value and the air might not
there might be areas at the your data
where things there might be clusters and
areas or things where the model doesn't
fit particularly well lastly this is a
pretty cool one for this government is a
discrimination thresholds for binary
classifiers so this one is visualizing
kind of an old data set hamper so spam
so simply if an email you get is the
class water determines is a hammer it's
spam and this discrimination threshold
in this one is logistical aggression
what is the decision threshold of
probability that it is spam or ham and
over X and as you go through each one of
those thresholds how is your model
performing you know we call precision
queue rate and what's not and here based
upon your business needs maybe you know
you're making a binary classification
for if someone is showing an ad or not
you can know based upon what you're
trying to optimize for there's a
precision and recall what is your
business sensitivity to kind of quick
very quickly hone in to where you want
to set that threshold so that's this
kind of a very quick introduction to
some of our visualizers so now I'm going
to kind of shift into the process of
developing a visualizer and we're kind
of gonna go into after you develop it
how we kind of package it and ship it so
what does visualizer a visualizer is a
generalized unit of work that in yellow
brick produces a matplotlib
visualization under the hood as I said
before it combines the business and
display logic for for fitting a model
then drawing whatever kind of outcomes
that we want on a visualization and it's
kind of glued together with with numpy
so getting even deeper in in Python a
visualizer it's an object well that's
not fair to say because everything in
Python is an object right and well a
visualizer is a defined class so a
defined class that has its instantiated
it has methods and properties and we use
that kind of class approach for how we
organize that logic for developing a
visualization or and in other word
developing a data data product you know
kind of visualizer and this kind of
pattern or organization will approach
the code allows us to reuse it Python we
have inheritance so we can use other
methods and properties that we inherit
from increases understand ability
because you have logical pieces of code
that may be that may be a little more
oriented to fitting and modeling versus
that that is drawing I'm gonna go
through examples a little while and you
can kind of kind of separate them
appropriately and lastly as soon as you
have your code that's properly separated
and clean and understandable it makes it
a lot easier to test and a document
which we will getting in towards the end
so the elaborate visualizer API there's
roughly four components to it
this is a little more simplified but
there's classes we have an init method
which generally is for configuration and
in most of our visualizers that includes
the model you're you're passing into
initialization the fit method where the
the transformation logic or the actual
fit modeling goes drawing drawing the
plot based upon the outcomes from fit is
all done by matplotlib
and then poof well poof finalizes the
plot and any other kind of like display
presentation logic and last to say we in
our model visualizers we wrap the
scikit-learn model inside of that so
after a visualization is done then a
user has access to the model one of the
things we're actively developing is
other modeling libraries like tensorflow
Kerris etc well not tensor flow but
other similar ones that use this
scikit-learn api passing that estimator
into a visualizer to to create
visualizations and help data science
data scientists better understand their
models so here we go let's build a
decision boundary visualizer this is
kind of like the 101 that beginning data
scientists and classes they normally
kind of see what is you know machine
learning and kind of what's going on so
as a disclaimer I borrowed this from
psychic learns nearest neighbor
classification example and this was also
one of the first ones that about two
years ago I took this example and as I
was learned that the the yellow-brick
API took this code and transformed this
into the yellow-brick API so anybody
want to take a shot what's going on here
sure you guys have seen this before so
we have boundaries anybody
yeah great so exactly so this under the
the data set I'm using here is the the
great twice that virus data set we've
all seen this before and this is what
this is representing here this is
k-means and after we train the model
this is kind of how the model sees the
world or at least in this kind of this
kind of space with the X and the y that
are being passed into it so for here
this boundary right here it it sees if
you pass in some one object to predict
this is what the model is going to
classify it as versus this kind of blue
area this is where the model sees that
and anything that's in that space is
classified accordingly in green and you
can you can see here how actually the
model for each one of these individual
instances kind of classify said yeah so
as we're building this we're gonna I'm
gonna kind of go through my common
workflow for building visualizer and I'm
sure many of you guys sorry
many of you all this is kind of a common
approach you have from experimenting
with getting your outcome and then
eventually refining refactoring it to
make it so you can reproduce and share
it with the rest of your team so step
one it's usually to get something
working so I can't really see this but
let me see it's a little smaller so
usually it's something where you're
loading you're cleaning the data and
after you have the data you're setting
your X&Y heard the scikit-learn pattern
and you set up some kind of matplotlib
you say hey this is the color scheme i
want to use there's noise everywhere
because you're trying to see the
outcomes you
in maybe one or many classifiers to it
or whatever you're trying to do it's
kind of noisy then you say okay I've
trained it now I want to do some more of
the drawing logic there's no comments
you're not really sure what's kind of
going on here this is like many of the
common notebooks that I do initially I
see some kind of nod to be like yeah
we've been here before
and then eventually you get to drawing
something and you're like well it works
alright we've all been there before
the last week is the same thing
and then when you kind of step back and
you're like this is really cool I got
this to work and then for some reason
your kernel dies or whatnot
and you hit restart and write all what
happens you kind of just broke
everything and oh wait you forgot to
import you know the data sets API or
module or whatnot things are out of
order as you kind of saw here before the
state on notebooks you know it's not
it's not linear it's it's kind of
skipping around a lot so step number one
and yellow-brick the common my common
development flow like for many of you is
getting something working learning you
know quick iterative development and the
key with visualizations you rapidly have
to get this feedback of how's the
visualization looking is it working you
know oh I'm am I missing the title or
this or that cons obviously it's messy
it's iterative development and obviously
it's not ready to ship step two step two
this is when you come back and you're
like whoa things weren't working before
how can I repay your falling Pepe Tour
memory or following your own kind of
like style guide and you're like okay
I'm gonna be a good
I'm gonna write some good Python code
I'm gonna put all my input
you know imports at the top right pep
eight then you're like I'm going to make
sure the model that I found that is the
best solution for this problem gonna
really clearly put it you know put it
somewhere else separate these concerns a
little bit same thing for the data maybe
you've already done that maybe you're
getting that from a separate system or
whatnot but that is something you kind
of separate you refactor out so it's
really clean it's not kind of splashed
everywhere same thing for configuration
maybe it's different from an input maybe
it's just like you know the light you
know how your styling something or these
like little optional parameters that you
kind of make another step in that too
or another thing is you might change
variable names so what was H before H
was a single letter variable that me
developer I look at that I'm like what
is H I guarantee in two weeks or three
weeks I'm gonna have no idea what that
is I'm seeing some nods so we have we
all been scarred by that before then you
separate it out and you're like okay
this is all the modeling code where all
the scikit-learn code let's keep this
nice and clean make it understandable
draw for everything you're doing to
produce your visualization or maybe it's
some other kind of output maybe it's
going into a web page at that point
you're going to kind of you know kind of
separate into a logical component and
hey look it works not even does it work
but it's clean you can understand to
your coworker and maybe it's something
you put online maybe you can share it
online for a project that you've done
step 3 applying this these components
into a pattern so this is kind of in an
yellow brick I skipped a slide right
they already talked about that though
applying these components into a pattern
so for me as I'm developing the
visualizer
and maybe whatever projects you're
working on there's usually kind of like
a pattern where things kind of fit into
it in this case for eulenberg I'm still
using the Jupiter notebook because
visualizations require very rapid
feedback on how the visualization is
looking how it's performing in this case
I'm going to inherit from base class we
have so we can access those other
methods and properties and I'm going to
add under just the code I'm gonna adjust
the code that we were some we had before
and put it into this like bigger clock
to how it will work in our API scheme so
applying the components into a pattern
and I'm just going to go this kind of
very quickly so inheriting from in this
case the yellow brick based visualizer
which contains a lot of common methods
and properties and the Anette method I'm
putting all the kind of configuration
I'm putting also as this one is
visualizing a model I'm also passing
that model in as part of the
instantiation and then I'm doing well
setting these other methods and
properties on it in the fid method I'm
placing all of this as we said before
fittings I could learn maybe some
transformation code in here as well
making a couple little changes so that
everything this kind of self-contained
in this class and then lastly or next
going and Russ all this drawing display
display logic putting this all into this
way this is almost exactly the same code
that we went two steps ago during our
iterative development then we refactored
now we're putting it into an API or a
clearly documented structure for how
this code is going to live and how it's
going to be used and lastly I didn't put
this in here both in there before but
this the poof method and the
yellow-brick API calls finalized and
finalized is where you get the nice
stuff like setting the title for your
visualization or also the the legend and
for just for convenience I put a fit
draw poof method on this so instead of
calling all all three or all two methods
you just have to call one and as you can
see fit draw called spit draw and poof
so now that we've applied this into the
common pattern we're going to go back
kind of go back to the method and just
kind of tested it works so first we're
setting our input data we're
instantiating our model and we're
running the visualizer and calling fit
Rob poof and hey look it works great we
have something that's reproducible we've
kind of captured all this logic into one
place
and then we got a visualization so what
next oh you guys need to do next well
yeah
mm-hmm yeah great question so one of the
things we can do so these are in Python
these are optional arguments or default
arguments so if we wanted to change
these colors we could just pass in light
colors here I don't have this set up but
like colors and then put something in
here right so amazing question that's
what we want to do in yellow brick any
other suggestions okay I'm gonna go so
what I would want to do next is hey we
we got this working for for nearest
neighbors
I want to see how another model
interprets sees this data how does it
work so what am I gonna do I'm going to
well yes it's smart yes it works I'm so
smart it's common reaction right so I'm
gonna test this with another model so
I'm gonna import import a random forest
instantiate it past that model in here
again hey look we have yes see that we
have this visualization here this is how
that model sees the world there sees
that data set how its gonna classify
accordingly as it's a random forest you
would kind of assume that however it's
interpreting the data it's made certain
roles that at two point five or whatnot
everything on the X label less than
let's say you know four point eight is
going to be this that to your turn so
clearly if we pass some more models into
this we can reproduce this visualization
and understand you know the model and
kind of its rules versus looking at you
know a list of numbers and kind of
trying to make a determination based
upon that about how the model is
performing cool so now that we've
applied this in the pattern it works
now what what do we what do we do
normally do what do you guys normally do
after this you got something working
something's performing well okay someone
gets a gold star
but that doesn't happen everywhere right
but what do you guys okay the answer is
right test document make it more stable
but in your common workflows I've worked
for several teams writing tests
sometimes there's not time right ship it
there you go
when I was working in journalism it's
just like hey good enough let's get on
the site our audience needs to see that
[Music]
but then here comes the question as
waste before the test or not to test so
again Wizard of Oz here but and this is
a flying monkey right here so the
question is releasing something and
yellow brick that's going to be consumed
by downstream users or it's going to be
used by paying customers we need to make
sure this stuff is solid right maybe
it's internal maybe it's a prototype
maybe show your boss maybe you don't put
tests but the lesser evil I would say is
writing some tests testing a little time
but quality stable product something you
can stand by was great so why write this
as I said stability controlling complex
systems this is a trivial example here
but in some of the pipelines out there
there's lots of data transformations
multiple models all kinds of stuff right
and humans make mistakes sometimes we
make a change things break we don't go
through that manual testing process to
confirm everything is working correctly
sometimes get just gets in our way how
many times has like a merge conflict and
broken something really important for
you guys
all the time right documentation
documenting how your system works and
what I what I say to my bosses at work
is as soon as we have
stable system we write some tests we
know it works we can go faster we can
build more complex cool things so here's
a simple test case this is our radial
visualizer
and this plots points along axis around
a circle to detect if features are
separating so what do you guys notice
about these two visualizations it's the
same day idea why not
well one is red has a circle and one is
not red right this is a get merge
conflict it's one line of code in one of
our visualizers and the question is if
you have 30 visualizers or you have a
massive product massive data product you
can't go and visually inspect every
single one to make sure it works so what
happened well there's a bug a flying
monkey got in our code there so how to
test against this so these really
inspected for every release mock all the
things which mocking in the Python world
is it can't be complicated there's a
learning curve and while I love
matplotlib and digging through its
internals writing test cases and mocking
that can I'd rather do other things
here's an example of mocking moppet
matplotlib I did this for yellow brick
before I found a better way lock legends
whatnot and there's many ways to do this
as a simple example
you're just testing that something's
called and we're doing visualizations
we're not testing that something called
example exactly we want to find a way to
know that our visualization is drawn
correctly and consistently so path to a
better way couple years ago in Python
2017 in Portland this is a big issue in
our you know in our growing library
simply into sprints I kind of thought
maybe someone else's had that problem
before so I did what I should have done
in the beginning I just read the
documentation
right read the docs guys but assuming
you guys writing developing these
features the people that the libraries
you're using most likely they've
encountered these problems before so
matplotlib they have an image comparison
test that in our group of core
contributors for yellow brick we're like
how do we do this how do we do this and
we said to read the docs then was there
it's great so this is what they do so
they have it's under the hood they call
it an image comparison test and they
compare the baseline image against what
you're actually producing in that
current time you're writing tests and it
produces diff file which as a human
visually you can clearly see the
difference right I can't see it from
here but I'm sure you guys can see it in
the back and includes a scoring metric
so if it it goes pixel by pixel and if
the images are different it compares it
returns a error metric and with the
tolerance I say if it's greater than
this well your your test is gonna fail
and pretty simply I used what I found a
met plot lib to add this to our test
suite and just do an image comparison
test so testing the actual visualizer
itself putting it in there and asserting
that it meets the baseline image yeah so
I'm sure some of you saw this and you're
like whoa that's a lot of hand artisanal
data right there so generating test data
for scikit-learn these are some of the
things that we're kind of running out of
time
these are easy utilities that when I've
explained this to people before a
there's these easy things for writing
tests and scikit-learn or matplotlib
people just need to know about them and
that's kind of like second half of the
talk that I just wanted to explain to
you guys so this is artisanal data right
handcrafted ham coded but can we do
better
well the scikit-learn
developers encountered this problem they
have a data set API for making make a
classification data set they also have
one for making a regression data set
also for making blobs for kind of for
clustering as well plug it in just don't
forget the random seed can anybody tell
me why yeah we want our test to be
deterministic so you write a test
they're gonna behave the same way each
time so putting it together now when we
write a test kind of very similar to the
pattern we followed before we
instantiate the model we create our test
data we pass it in to our model we call
our method we do other kind of you know
test testing the features we didn't talk
about that make making sure other
attributes and properties are there and
then we do an image similarity test to
make sure what was drawn versus what the
baseline it's stable and it exists also
don't have a lot of time but number
numpy there's also an assert a certain
array equal you test method you can use
these are the stuff that these guys know
about it's gonna make your testing a lot
easier so to summarize clean
well-structured code is you know just to
start it's gonna make it I don't even
have to explain this to you guys it's
gonna make your life easier
read the development contributor
documentation these libraries have
encountered the same problem so you have
before in the past and they've most
likely come up with the solutions
sometimes you're gonna have to dig into
the source code set up and follow
patterns api's or whatever to make your
life easier
understand how code is structured and
where it lives and share what you've
learned with others I've had this
talking to me for a couple in couple of
years and the reason that I come to
conferences like this is to learn from
other people and I'm really happy that I
had
chance to share with you guys I have one
more slide after this yellow brick we're
looking for contributors come talk with
me and really important I just want to
give some shoutouts to my mentors first
Rami Chaudhary Rebecca dobro Benjamin
bend forward they really spent a lot of
time they're my friends but I feel like
they're mentors this journey I'm on you
guys are on to you know it's a community
help each other and to tell you guys
that PI data attendees committee numb
focus thank you guys so much
and to yellow brick users contributors
maintain errs this was us at PyCon 2018
Sprint's very successful print sprints
tons of PRS onboarding new people it's
great community anyway that's it thank
you guys
[Applause]
all right so we've got about ten minutes
for questions if anybody has anything
they'd like to ask Nathan yeah I'll come
around with the mic so can you feed in
an already fit model into the visualizer
workflow or do you have to it seemed
like part of it it it just depends on
the on the visualizer I would recommend
just looking at the documentation but
yes generally our visualizers will
accept fitted models
that's a great question and I think you
know part of it is I think it's just how
how this project like grew when
matplotlib got started it you know
scikit-learn didn't exist and this this
exact problem didn't really exist yet I
would say that part of it is just you
know kind of the open source community
and kind of figuring out ways to kind of
collaborate and how to kind of like
maybe join or you know better
collaborate so that it's really this
kind of a community question I think
right anybody else alright well Nathan
thank you so much for your talk on
yogurts
[Applause]